today's questions from Tammy in New
Jersey do you consider pension payments
and deferred compensation taken out of
my check as part of your 15% towards
retirement in baby step four if so then
I should just just take the extra money
and put it in mutual funds
what deferred comp is a choice deferred
comp is a 457 and that's just something
like a 401 K I would do a 401 K or a
403b in good mutual funds before I would
do deferred comp if you have pension
payments that are required and are
mandatory and are removed from your
check whether you want them to or not in
other words then I would not count them
a hundred percent towards the 15 percent
because you're not in control of that
money if you have a 401 K with a hundred
thousand dollars in it and your company
goes broke you don't lose a dime because
the 401 K with hundred thousand dollars
in is in your name if you have a hundred
thousand dollars in your pension and the
company goes broke you lose all your
money the pension is an asset of the
company not you and so you ever heard
the story you know the company went
broke I lost my pension you ever heard
that that's because that happened that's
where why people say stuff like that now
doesn't happen that often and most
companies are managing their pension in
a you know a fairly conservative decent
way they're not crooked they're not
backward they've got a lot of
regulations on them so I'm not panicking
you about your pension but because you
don't have control of that money it is
not in your name no I would save as much
as I can outside of that up to 15% but
let's say you work for an agency that
requires you to put ten percent of your
income into that what I had then do five
percent in 403 B's or 401 K or 457 s no
I would do a little more than five I'd
probably do 10 I probably count that 10%
at about a 50 percent mark in other
words whatever amount they're having you
put in count about half of it towards
your 15%
I'm gonna discount it in other words
because it's not in your name that's
what it amounts to because I want a
bunch of money piled up in your name the
goal here is not how little can I say
the goal here is how wealthy can I
become and that's based on how much you
saved not how little you save so you
know let's ask the question of how I can
put more in not how I can put less in
but overall that gives you something to
think about there and the 4:57 again is
not a mandatory thing that's deferred
comp deferred comp means you simply
didn't take the compensation now it's
set aside for you so you haven't yet
paid taxes on it which is the same thing
as a pre-tax 401k works the same way as
far as the tax part of it goes and if
it's invested in the same mutual funds
you know have the exact same result as a
pre-tax 401k I'd rather you do Roth 401
case if you have that available